-Here with the TV debut
of their new songs "Lifetime"
and "It Gets Better,"
with special guests
Ty Dolla $ign and 070 Shake,
here's Swedish House Mafia!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Echoing ] ♪ Once, once ♪
♪♪
-♪ Once in a lifetime,
watching the skyline ♪
♪ Don't change your mind while
under the white light ♪
♪ Once in a lifetime,
watching the skyline ♪
♪ Don't change your mind while
under the white light ♪
-♪ Dolla Sign,
once in a lifetime ♪
♪ Baby, it's the right time ♪
♪ I'll put on the red light,
told you it was on site ♪
♪ You had on that sun dress,
never fail to impress ♪
♪ We had the best sex,
we made love all night ♪
-♪ All night ♪
♪ Once in a lifetime,
watching the skyline ♪
♪ Don't change your mind while
under the white light ♪
♪ Once in a lifetime,
watching the skyline ♪
♪ Don't change your mind while
under the white light ♪
-[ Scatting ]
♪♪
-♪ Come with me, take my hand ♪
♪ Follow me, follow me ♪
♪ To a place, a place
where we can be free ♪
♪ Follow me ♪
-[ Fading ] ♪ Once in a
lifetime, watching the skyline ♪
♪ Don't change your mind while ♪
♪♪
-[ Distorted ]
♪ It gets better, babe ♪
♪ It gets better, it gets
better, it gets ♪
♪ It gets better,
it gets better, it gets ♪
♪ It gets better, it gets
better, it gets ♪
♪ It gets better,
it gets better, it gets ♪
-♪ Let me, let me love you,
let me love you ♪
♪♪
-♪ Let me love you ♪
♪ It gets better, baby ♪
♪♪
♪ I want you, baby, yeah ♪
♪ It gets better, baby, whoo ♪
♪ Let me love you ♪
♪♪